branle bas de combat à moscou les
autorités sanitaires de la capitale ont
décrété un état d' alerte élevée et une
série de nouvelles mesures pour empêcher
la propagation du coronavirus prions
ainsi toutes personnes rentrant de pays
infectés de s'isoler d'elle-même les
contrôles sont renforcés dans les
transports et les lieux publics
tout comme les désinfections dans la
sphère professionnelle
les responsables sont priés de garder un
oeil sur l'état de santé de leur
collègue pour détecter les signes de la
maladie
toute personne présentant une
température élevée est alors suspendu de
son lieu de travail
si un cas est confirmé les employeurs
sont tenus d'informer les autorités de
tous les contacts possibles sur le lieu
de travail et de désinfecter les
bâtiments où la personne contaminée a pu
se rendre alors que moscou prend des
mesures pour enrayer l'épidémie
washington accuse au contraire la russie
de propager de fausses informations sur
le virus
une responsable du département d'état a
pris la parole devant le congrès pour
imputer à la russie les messages
conspirationnistes publié sur internet
et sur les réseaux sociaux en
particulier richard jenkins avons vu
l'ensemble de l'écosystème riche de
désinformation en marche les sites web
aura jusqu'à sont des marionnettes du
gouvernement les médias officiels d'état
ainsi que les nuées de faucon est en
ligne promouvez des idées fausses la
dénonciation de ces ruses et à l'aide de
notre coopération avec les médias a
permis de renforcer la sensibilisation
sur cette question et d'expliquer qu'il
y avait beaucoup de désinformation
j'espère que désormais tous les acteurs
agiront de manière plus responsable afin
de soutenir les gens qui partent dans le
monde sont effrayés par cette crise
l'envoyé spécial du département d'état a
refusé d'entrer dans les détails de la
soi-disant opération de désinformation
russe elle prétend en effet qu'elle ne
veut pas risquer de leur donner une
quelconque crédibilité
mais d'autres responsables n'ont pas eu
cette délicatesse et on déclarait que
cette opération de désinformation se
concentre autour de trois récits le
chrono virus est en fait une arme
biologique
la cia a créé le virus pour faire du
tort à la chine ou encore bill gates est
à l'origine du virus
autant de faits que nous attribuer à la
russie ce que regrette vladimir poutine
je cassais sauf en ce qui concerne ces
histoires provoquant le fsb rapportent
qu'ils sont principalement augmenté à
l'étranger
mais ce n'est malheureusement toujours
un petit teaser d'autant que les
services techniques des réseaux sociaux
en question interrogé sur le sujet n'ont
pas pu fournir d'éléments qui viennent
étayer ses accusations
de façon générale notre enquête n'a pas
confirmé cette affirmation
nous avons demandé des preuves qui
viennent appuyer ses accusations mais
nous n'avons encore rien reçu comme
souvent moscou est accusé de bien des
maux la capitale russe a actuellement
d'autres chats à fouetter
face à la menace du coronavirus il
semble que pour le coup tout le monde
soit dans le même bateau